The joe rogan experience,
the Ron Paul's of the world,
you know,
it's like to get to be a
certain age where they're just,
they don't give a fuck.
Like what are you going to do?
Are you going to shoot him?
He's fucking 85 years
old or whatever he is.
You know,
he's,
he's last run for president has done
now it's up to his son and his son.
Apparently he's been using cheat sheets.
Plagiarizing a lot of credit for that
wonderful filibuster we did for the fourth
amendment,
got the best publicity,
the fourth amendment's gotten in so
long and then you go pull that on me.
Make me look like an idiot for beef.
People don't know what
you're talking about.
It's apparently he had used some,
some words from some various speeches.
Exactly the same.
Exactly.
Is it possible that he has writers and
he doesn't know that's what his father
shot the newsletters where that
got his father in so much trouble.
But remember Rand Paul who website
nice things about also has his,
one of his main advisors,
that guy who did the southern Avenger,
you know cafe.
Oh yeah.
The Guy,
one of his advisors was the southern
Avenger and he wore a mask and had a
confederate flag behind him,
like a youtube show or something,
and then when they said it,
you're going to fire this guy.
He goes something like,
well,
that's all in his past
and you just go ice.
What's up with this?
Why are these people all crazy?
Talk about freedom in our constitution.
You're crazy.
That's adorable.
Yeah.
Maybe it's the southern Avenger.
Look at his photo.
Oh wait.
If that guy's on your staff and somebody,
you could honestly say,
God,
I didn't know he was a southerner venture.
Once they tell you,
don't you fire him five seconds later,
I think it's probably a good move.
That to me,
right?
There you go.
Great.
Thanks for taking my pet issue of the
fourth amendment and trashing it with your
southern Avenger guy.
What is the southern Avenger stance?
Maybe I'm on his team.
Hold on us.
I know I have never
watched the southern event.
I just clips painting
with a broad blush brush.
The confederate flag does that for you.
I don't know.
What could he possibly,
he's confusing the shit out of me already.
Conservative,
Libertarian,
Independent.
What he's done,
he's,
he's just,
he's destroyed conservative,
independent and libertarian
in one tag line.
He's probably,
you know,
working for a group whose design,
who's trying to discredit
all of those things.
I'm surprised it doesn't
have a TM at the end of it.
You know,
it's the logo.
It's a better logo that
a lot of people have.
Yeah.
I mean,
what does he try to do?
Is this guy still like a wrestler?
Doesn't eat.
He does.
Is He still have a show?
No,
we works for Rand Paul now.
Still.
They didn't fire him in.
Where's Brian?
He keeps supposed to look all that.
He's not going to look it up.
He's just going to interrupt.
Oh,
he's been panic.
Temporary banishment but ran.
Paul still has this guy working for,
I can't imagine.
I can't comment on that.
As we know,
if the southern Avenger said anything bad,
he says,
speak at the same conference as Rand Paul.
After neoconservative
alter ego was revealed.
Hunter left a post on the,
as the Kentucky senators social media.
I'm like,
that's the guy that's
southern or avenger please.
I was,
I couldn't see it.
It looks like guys look at that photo
over his right shoulder for the left
shoulder.
That's disturbing.
Is that I have no shirt on.
There's like a bunch of people
and one guy has no shirt on.
That's a gay orgy about
a southern gay orgy.
They just said,
we just have some chicken
and we're fixing to fuck.
Look at him.
The guy has no shirt on
and a big chest tattoo.
What if that chest tattoo was
like some fucking conservative?
You don't know what's
on his bank statement.
Yeah,
a big confederate flag.
I'm sure the cover of the fucking,
the roof of the general duty.
How come?
Whenever you get someone who sang some
important things in a halfway decent way,
they have to come.
You know,
people say to me all the time,
well we vote all the time Dan.
The of course the countries on.
Is it based on voters voting for people?
How come?
When we get somebody who would like
to change course in a direction,
most of us would like to see half of them
is really fantastic and the other half
of them is so crazy.
You'd never elect a person
like that in a million years.
Why can't we have somebody who has some
common sense and it doesn't sound like
two words,
my friend simulation theory and all
guys back and diversify risk management
diversification tool.
Yeah.
I wonder,
you know,
I think he's hedging his bets in case
white people take over the world again,
you know,
in in,
in a,
in a very dominant sort of way.
We'll have the southern Avenger on staff.
He can advise us.
You ever watched those extreme preppers
shows that little shows her dudes or,
or fix into the preparing
for the end of the world.
People stockpile and water and creating
escape routes and battering rams.
They're welding to the front
of their pickup trucks.
The hoarders because they're the porters
that are doing it for a good cause,
right?
Yeah.
They believe that it's all going
to come crumbling down and those,
I think that there's an mentality and
the same kind of mentality that is the
type of person that wants to get in
this word rebellious position of power,
rebellious position of,
you know,
railing out against the government.
They're very similar to these people
that are prepping is very similar to the
their extreme folks.
Like those are the only people that
make it to the front of that crazy line.
They have to be a bit nutty.
It's not that the ideas aren't interesting
to you or I when look at a guy like
ran Paul,
the things that he says that
you agree with or his dad,
the things that he says
that you agree with,
but it's to get there.
He's facing so much opposition.
There's so much bullshit along the way,
so much pressure,
so much,
so much back and forth debate.
So much frustration,
so much suppression of information.
By the time he gets to a position
where the world is listening to him,
he's already broken.
He like broke every bone in his fucking
soul just to get to the front of the
line.
You know,
it's funny that people
say to me all the time,
you know,
can you get a staff together to do
what you do so you can do better?
I want more history shows.
Can we,
can we help you do this?
And I always say the same thing.
I said,
you can't help me because I can't watch
y'all and I can't keep track of them.
That's what all these people do.
They,
you know,
what was it?
Uh,
Paul said,
uh,
Ron Paul said,
well,
this guy who wrote,
he was doing my newsletter for me.
I was in Congress.
I didn't have time to do newsletters.
So he did it and he wrote all this stuff
and I didn't know what was happening.
That's my fear is that you can hire a
bunch of people and then you're gonna turn
around and go,
what did you do for me?
What you,
which we started the southern
Avenger show for you.
We thought that'd be a good
promotional vehicle for your show,
Dan.
No doubt.
Yeah,
no doubt.
I think that there's,
it's a catch 22 do you,
do you give away some of your
control or do you keep it,
you know,
where you know everything's cool,
but the minute you give it away,
you got rogue people,
you know with your name running
around graffitiing the PSI,
Banksy and Carlin,
we're here.
So many isolated the photograph,
pull it.
This is the photograph.
It's all a bunch of wrestlers.
Like a wrestler.
Yeah.
These are like old school southern
wrestlers that I was probably right.
They probably buff fucked each other.
As soon as this was over.
And this guy's got this in the,
the,
well,
he's got it framed on his wall in
the background of his fucking study.
So yay.
Southern Avenger.
Yay.
Simulation theory.
Does it say he parted ways?
So there so,
so he got rid of him finally,
I guess the,
the hue and cry was a little too much
for a sitting senator from Kentucky to
have somebody named the
southern Avenger on his staff.
Well,
he was a cogo coauthor of
the 2011 book with Rand Paul.
The tea party goes to watch,
maybe forgotten,
blanked it out.
But you're right.
It's,
it is funny that these people,
they have to be,
we can't have a fourth
amendment person who's not.
I mean,
I guess you do,
you got guys like widen and you'd
all in some of these people,
but,
but when you get somebody who's a
real lightening rod for this stuff.
Yeah.
And you think,
finally,
we've been waiting for
a guy like this forever.
They come with these poison pills
that you just can't swallow.
Okay.